Get excited for the videooo~
YEAH~!
*mutual screaming*
Pewdiepie: SO EXCITED!
...
*crying*
Time to look at Reddit, they were looking at AskReddit.
Sounds great ,free content
Another day another free content.
I like how the top one here says:
"How do you feel about the recent Youtube videos propreting off of people's Askreddit threads."
That's not what's happening At AlL!
We gotta start giving credit to all these individuals that're stealing other people's memes.
Ah ahaha
Noooo
Dr.Phil says " One of these guys actually asked my permession to read my story on this show so i'm absolutely fond of it
I hope- i hope most of these Youtubers do this."
Dr.Philly!
Is that all i had to do to not get copy-striked?!
YoU jUsT aSk. (x2)
What the hell?!
Come on Sonny, come on.
"When you realize this will be on Youtube. [insert surprised Pikatchu face ]"
OH WOHOHO
Oh it's a mada
What is happening?
"Which celebrity is NOT  as nice as they seem?"
Y'know...I'm super nice
You are...
I'm so--...aghfk I'm wat?
I'M WHAT?!
At least i'm honest in my videos about how i am.
I-I-I don't put on....like- *laughs*
YOU'RE SO NICE! YOU'RE SO NICE!
You are-- You're the nicest.
Yeah? y-ye..
SAY I'M NICE !
(you) nice..
Alright, let's see..what celebrities are not nice.
"Luke Bryan... is a POS," they said.
Who the frick is Luke Bryan?!
Well is that the guy from like- uhh..
I have no idea what this is..
Oh, you can tell just by looking at him. I don't mea- i don't need someone on Reddit to tell me this.
*chuckles*
Anyone that dress and looks like this..
Sorry Luke we don't know anything about you
And this could be completely defenetory
But you're a doucheBAG!
UUGH
You got that CR TV back there for , what you got that for?
MEEMEES
It looks like it's freaking fire hazardous and could explode and kill everybody.
Look at the wires coming from it.
That what i'm hoping for.
Goddamn
Said we gonna make another Happy Wheels
Hoping that the TV will one day just @!#$ing explode
*BOOM*
Sorry this meme's taken way longer than I expected.
*laughs* You can't see anything
What- what did you put in it?
Oh is that a-- is that a..
AH no-o-o- *laughs*
No don't put me on it! NOOO~
HAHAhaha..
But Senpai...
Dude, look how dank Edgar's..
Look at him he's like "Yeaaaah~~"
"Frank Sinatra once called my grandfather an !@#$ (x2) at blackjack table-- at a blackjack table just for sitting there.
Well it sounds like your grandad is an !#@hole you just exposed your Granddad and not Frank Sinatra
JEEZ
I mean you've had a blackjack table , you've got the good cards, someone sits down
and messes up the cards you've gotten = They're an asshole !
Was a waitress at a restaurant that had celebrity clients..
Uh-huh.
Larry David:  Super nice
YASS
Good job LARRY :)
Alec baldwin: he's sweaty..
He's sweaty??!
Eww
Sweat Alec Baldwin.
This changes everything I can't watch..
*laughs*
"Alecia Keys, I worked security at a local concert venue for over 10 years and whe was absolutely
the meanest artist that i ever rubbed elbows with."
Oh then don't be rubbing elbows then it's weird!
Personal Space (ewww)
"..Being so close i was able to hear every word she said to her assistant , and it wasn't pretty.
She basically bad mouthed the entire group.
She had something negative to say about almost everyone's outfits and appearance.
Considering how long ago it was, I hope she has grown up.."
Remember how-w w-we did the Meet And Greets
I remember you and I would sit next to each other
and we had this a... uh--
what's it called?...
Like the..hand sanitizer..
Uhh? ye..
It just feels so mean to like..You meet all these fans,and then yo go like..
Ewww
*laugh*
It gets sick though , you like--you get sick of all the jerks though..
*incoherent mumbling*
Ayy , have you ever had someone sit besides and people like-- y'know get you an autograph
And then they're like " Get the PD autograph  for me." and like "Thanks."
*wheeze*
"But hey man we know who you are but hey sign this-"
I'm like like F*** you i just have to say that you piece o' --
"Someone i know met Adam Levine backstage and was mad because he told Adam:
" You guys are good :D "
and Adam said " I know "  and (oooh) walked off."
Hahaha, "I thought it was funny because the guy took it personal"
I mean come on.. ThEy KnOw
Right??
They know everybody loves them it's funny- Adam Levine
Is it the guy in Maroon 5?
Uhh I think so..
"All i can say is is met Mark Hamill at deli and he was so damn cool, kind and generous.
I asked for a picture and he happily obliged
"I'm on the tall side, 6'5 ,"
Is that ain't even tall?
"When I went to lean down to get the photo he said no leaning down and instead I --
instead got on his tippy toes. True jedi master."
Man, this makes me feel bad like, *clears throat* more and more now, when i get recognised
I'd say "No" at this situation, it's really bad
(YeaH) But i mean, me and Mark --said-- drove back home and i was really late.
and we were super hungry, we drove to this Mcdonald's drive-thru, and were like:
"Please don't.. we just wanna eat, and don't wanna be recognised
and all these kids come up to us and one of their mom's kinda- goes like:
"CAN I TAKE A PHOTO
WITH MY SON?"
and i was just like, "Sorry, i'm just tryna have dinner.."
*giggles awkwardly*
And I just felt- I feel like the worst--
You gonna be here somewhere ( i think)
Y-yea I..
honestly I feel like- I feel like the worst person ever, I just wish -like, they understand we're coming..
Yea~
Just eating or doing something,  I don't wanna exit my car to take a photo.
Yea..
Oh well that like uhh-- well
A lot a these.. a lot of these situations , like the ones in this Reddit
Say if you go out, you have like a day you're walkin'
and like,o- for 8 hours. like 7 to 8 hours you get asked to take pictures and stuff
and that ONE person that catches you when you're like at your
(Right, Right) lowest is gonna be here making a post about it.
And they're like they're- they're gonna wanna experience, even though , they're like the 8th hundered person you've seen that day.
"And I met Pewdiepie one time"
uhhh-ye
"...it was at 3A.M and he was asleep and i was in his room" *laughs*
".and he was rude and called the police on me."
EeEeeweEWEeweE
Goddamn..
"I used to know someone who produced
a Toby Maguire movie and claimed that he is not a very nice person at all."
(noo~) no..
He was Spooderman!! ><
he was SPIDERMAN!
*laughs mixed with sobs*
Tiger Woods is a goddamn !@#$
Who would've thoght?
Who woulda thought it?
"I met Usher at a party once. One of the rudest most diva-like people--"
*ROAR*
GODAYUM
Ah come on
If we just just got you at the same party that would be gonna- be cool. That sure, alright..
"Another dude asked to take a picture with him and he was like:
*chuckles*
"How about you go to get another drink instead?" and walked off.
God damn - daaaaamn
But (ugh) Sherks bother poor Usher he's just trying there to support his friend and there he was like
like, making it about Usher
like, he's just..y'know..the man-- (ThAt'S RiGgHtT) yea (x2)
I'm sure Usher..uh-- you should be thankful for him being there, okay?
That's roight!
There--He gave you this story that you can share on Reddit, like
gave you a lot of points (yea) so..
You're welcome. ( you thought about that? you're welcome.)
"My friend met Patrick Sterwart (uh) in a pub during his stag do.
Since it was a stag they figured they should make it memorable so his friend approached sir Stewart and says:
"I'm sorry to ask this bu..."
Stewart interrupts him and says " Then don't."
*laughs* oooooh hoo hoo hoo hoo..
When you can't say stuff step up for that one:
I'm sorry to ask this-to ask this (lag) well then don't ask me if you're sorry.
Just don't do it, and you won't be sorry about it, alright? GOT' EM
OOOH got e-- yeah that's right, yeah, that's right.
For quick flaw, no flaws to the logic.
What's a stag do?
I think it's when uhh- someone gets married
It's like party?
I dunno :/
Stag party.Yea-yea i guess so.
Wea-well-wat what's the do tho??
You do the stag party.
's that like a Mountain Dew
You do Mountains Dews at the stag party ( why is this so hard to undresatand?) yes.
*gasp*
wow!
*clears throat*" Robin Williams" (uhh)
Who was very similar-uhh
Oh no don't. (uhh) don't even.
"He used to live in my neighborhood ..and i'd sometimes see him in a favorite restaurant.
"He'd be tucking his face out of ciew s it was clear he didn't want to be disturbed, so almost nobody...did.
Once i saw walk up to him anf say something i couldn't heat, and Robin was like:
"Dude, do you mind? I'm just trying to have dinner with my family." "
(pewds fanboys in distance) "Couldn't blame him in the least."
(yea-i) So that's a thing :D ?
Honestly...i hundred per cent ..undrestand that.
When you just ( yea) wanna do something.. with-uh with your loved ones
That's when it gets a little-uhh bothering.
y'know..(yeaah)
"My dad once met Adam Stanler at a bar in the Bahamas." Nooo..no
Adam Stanler..not Adamn Stanleeer
"Said he was just super down to earth all around awesome guy. The opp-
YAAY :D
Now i can still enjoy Click, my favorite movie!
oh thank God! (your favorite moviee!) All the ladies in Adam Stanler's the video are the best
Grown Ups 3! Grown Ups 3!
*cheers and laughs*
Have you met anyone that...was a ..was a nice?
Kind of a thing you find in anyone..
Well i've been to, like, conventions and stuff.. with, like, other..
i go like, i'd like..anime and gaming conventions with, like, other people, and the "business" y'know.
(ah let's see..it's the tea..) It's always like the most insane freaking people that are, like..
the worst.
*evil laughter*
"D'you know who i am?" No actually, i don't
Why did you do it?
y'know i don't !@#$ing care!
"I voice acted one character in a popular video game that's already dying. I'm a diva now" and i was like-
WOOOOO!
Let's have a tea sup-yea *laugh in background*
UGHH
I think mission completed here today.
The biggest tension of all time, basically.
Thanks you Askreddit for letting us steal your content.
But we are not worthy
We of course asked everyone for their permession
Yes.
Obviously
Mmhm :|
I wish to go back (it's uploaded by now)
Is it -Is is okay?
*laughs*
Thanks Ken for joining! really thank-
Hey thanks for having me, broo~
If can--let's me another relevant anymore, check out Ken's channel.
He just videos, guys. let's give him a petty sub at least.
ye-jus-jus-justt, no one(s) out there, man,- y'know.
Let me feel like a part of something.
Where the hell is my petty sub? okay?
WHUT ?! ):D I-UH- something- what are you taking about?
Prove it.
But we did last time...
The Most Dangerous Game.
Are you still surprised?
er-yye of course..I turned my notifications off though.
Alright,guys see you later
BYE!